okay we've been talking for years about
how we might be able to in some way
expand the offerings of the David Pakman
show
to appeal also to reach more people who
don't speak English or maybe don't speak
English well enough to really watch like
political discussion shows like this one
what why might we be able to do the sort
of obvious idea in terms of another
language would be Spanish I'm from
Argentina my first language is Spanish I
learned English as a second language
when I moved here and Spanish would be
the sort of natural way to go in my mind
number one because it's the only other
language I speak fluently and also
because it seems like it would be a good
target population in the United States
given that we mostly deal with American
politics because of the increased
importance of the Spanish speaking a
voter in influencing elections in the
United States now from a practical
standpoint we're pretty busy just doing
the show in English that we do and the
bonus show for members in English that
we do and live streams in English that I
do so the idea of me doing an entire
additional show in Spanish seems to sort
of stretch the limits of what is
possible given that the day's 24 hours
long and I also need some time to sleep
but I was contacted by two graduate
students who developed a system that can
take our captions we now caption all of
our content on YouTube in English
obviously they've developed a system
that can take those captions dub them
into other languages including Spanish
and then sync them to the original
videos that we are doing now it's not
perfect but it's very interesting here's
a clip just 45 seconds from one of the
stories I did on Monday where the
captions were taken turned into a
Spanish narration and then placed over
the video from that day take a look well
fin de semana realmente loco a where
Adela Casa Blanca Donald Trump sufrió
una fusion extraña extraña por una
historia del Washington Post sobre two
eighths
Elysee so in VR Thwaites Alma's locos
ah si que el sábado de bas in Tom post
escribió sobre lost weights resisted a
Donald ramp el Domingo Tassie como el
dia mas tarde
Tran Paso su manana perdiendo la cabeza
por el lo hacen tone publicar historia y
uno de los demás desi articulo del
Washington Post case a octovamp lament a
a pesar de los sweats fiestas a punto de
ver el OS in tone post is oun muy buen
trabajo La Casa Blanca elude our assess
ORS legisladores yacht rosie a participa
Ron en el manejo de tram pays en
respuesta a lagu herro well Bal Fiasco
de su piya's original básicamente
compartir o la misma perspectiva con el
juez in compost okay so anybody who
speaks Spanish will realize it is not
perfect but we started uh the David
Pakman show in English to reach as many
people as possible and to try to
influence politics and policy to the
extent that we are able in a way that we
think is for the betterment of the
country what we could do is start a
second YouTube channel the David Pakman
show
Spanish on a daily basis all of the
content we do on the regular David
Pakman show channel in English could be
dubbed and put on the David Pakman show
Spanish Channel it would be the same
stories it would be the same content
dubbed to Spanish the downsides are it's
not perfect like I said obviously it
would be better for me to just do the
entire show again in Spanish but it's
just not possible it's not practical
another downside is we'd be starting
from scratch with an audience
most of our current audience is an
english-speaking audience and even the
even though Spanish is a language that
is often taken by people in high school
college whatever the majority of our
audience is not going to switch over or
be interested in the David Pakman show
in Spanish so we're sort of like
starting from scratch trying to build a
new audience the other downside is this
is not free right there's a cost to
getting the dubbed videos to managing an
additional YouTube channel the upsides
are similar or related to the downsides
it is a completely new market on the one
hand we're starting from scratch trying
to build an audience in Spanish but it
is a completely new market I believe
it's a valuable service to people who
live in the United States but don't
speak English well enough to consume
political content
English they could become engaged the
other upside is I don't know of any
other American progressive media show
that is doing something like this and
sometimes being the first to do
something can be a really great
advantage and provide something that is
extraordinarily valuable so we could get
this going relatively quickly if we
decide to I want to hear from you what
do you think about this is it good
enough to warrant doing should be be
waiting for some better technology
should we just look at translating the
captions to Spanish yeah seems less
engaging for sure this would be a
channel with spanish-language titles
Spanish descriptions it would all be in
Spanish so I think it's interesting I
want to hear from you contact me by
email this is the best way now when I
really want to hear serious commentary
from the audience use the contact form
at david pakman.com to get in touch and
tell me what you think about this idea